bounce back to say the least as we head
over to Jen Hill Jen a bounce back
indeed Joel the Pelicans snap a six-game
winning streak by the Timberwolves and
get revenge for two earlier losses this
season Z they are the best defense in
the NBA and you put up 16 more points on
them than most opponents do how did this
team score
tonight uh we trusted each other and we
executed the charity stripe as well they
usually hold opponents to about 20
attempts per game you got the line 40
times so often you and bi don't get
those calls what was the key to getting
them tonight I mean we just stayed
aggressive U you know we were able to
get calls tonight Carl Anthony towns
only two points in that second half what
did you like about your defense on him I
mean like I've been saying we we stayed
aggressive on him her dice NJ they all
play good defense on them even be uh
like I said we execute on offense and
defense and we were able to get the win
absolutely now you were coming off a
very disappointing loss to the Lakers a
lot of people wondering how you would
respond to that game as a squad what do
you think this win says about this
Pelican Squad as a whole I mean we've
been through tougher moments but uh no
we're really resilient so I think that
show that showed tonight and I'm just
happy we got to win statement win Z
thanks for your time we'll see you on
the road thank you guys thank you Jen
now I said to you while Jen was talking
his eye on CJ was amazing in the second
half and what he did to start the fourth
and I said to you during the commercial
timeout he was
rested